The results are in and the U.S. intelligence
community, the Mueller Report, and the Senate Intelligence Committee all agree.
Russia interfered with the 2016 U.S. presidential
election.
And there’s good evidence that Russian President
Vladimir Putin personally ordered these attacks.
The goal was to weaken Hillary Clinton’s
campaign and undermine the U.S. electoral process.
According to the Mueller Report, the government of Russia perceived it would benefit from
a Donald Trump presidency and worked to secure that outcome.
Of course, there is still sharp partisan debate
about how much this Russian meddling affected
the final outcome of the 2016 race because nobody really knows for sure.
There is also partisan debate about what steps the U.S. must take to prevent this sort of thing from happening again.
But first, let’s go back to 2016.
Russian state-backed media published false
stories about Clinton.
Then hundreds of Russian backed trolls, often posing as Americans, posted those stories on social media.
On Facebook alone, those posts reached over 140 million people.
And Russian hackers leaked emails from the Democratic National Committee and Clinton campaign chair John Podesta.
But it didn’t stop there.
Moscow also targeted election systems in all
50 states.
They went after voter data and the machines
that tally and store votes.
Russian hackers came close to changing or
deleting votes in at least one state.
And while there’s no evidence they altered
voter information, it shows how vulnerable our elections truly are.
2016 wasn't an isolated incident.
In the 2018 midterm elections, Russian trolls
spread disinformation and stirred up divisions
on issues like abortion and gun control.
Intelligence officials believe they will interfere again in 2020.
In fact, it's probably already underway.
And it’s not just happening in the United
States.
There is strong evidence that Russia has tried to meddle in the affairs of at least 27 other countries since 2004.
Canada, the United Kingdom, Ukraine, and Germany have all been targeted.
So how can the U.S. keep its elections safe from foreign interference?
For starters, the U.S. can try to deter Russian
cyber aggression.
This means sanctioning Russian officials and
showing that the U.S. can launch counter-attacks.
Washington can make voting systems more difficult
to hack in the first place.
Election officials can back up machines with paper ballots and use other safeguards in case those hackers do break in.
Congress can also start to regulate social
media sites to stem the flood of misinformation.
Social media companies have made some moves
on their own, like hiring fact-checkers to review posts.
But many say these companies need to be forced
to do more, like disclose who’s paying for political ads on their sites.
Since 2016, some things have been done.
Both the Obama and Trump administrations imposed
sanctions on Russian individuals and entities.
Under President Obama, 35 Russian diplomats
were expelled.
The FBI and other intelligence agencies,
they are spending more time and resources on investigating electoral foul play.
Congress has allocated $380 million dollars
to states to better protect the vote.
Many states are now investing in new machines, better software, and preparing for post-election audits for 2020.
Unfortunately, experts say it will take billions
to truly secure elections.
And electoral security is now becoming a
divisive political issue.
President Trump has referred to reports of
meddling as a “hoax.”
And he has dismissed warnings about
the 2020 elections.
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell has also accused Democrats of playing up Russian interference for political gain.
As a result, greater voter protections have
stalled.
And American votes remain vulnerable to future
attacks.